well welcome everyone welcome welcome
thrilled to have you here for the bellos
lecture thanks for joining us today it's
great to see this crowd from all over
and those of you who also may be joining
us by streaming we will be able to tape
this bellows talk and be able to put on
website afterwards for those who were
not absolutely able to be here with us
today however it is great to be together
so for those of you who might not had
the pleasure of meeting yet I'm the Dean
and Cerf I just want to give you a bit
of background about our program before I
introduce our esteemed speaker today so
the bellows of lecture is one of our
signature events at the school here and
I know many of you look forward to this
program every year it's always a
highlight so the simple Palmer bellows
was an extraordinary was best known for
her work with immigrant families in New
York City she graduated the class of
1927 which was one of myosins
earliest classes a few of us including
Helen Bernie I'll just mention we're
trying to put together a timeline of the
school that we're gonna be able to put
up on the walls around here you know and
so you'll see circulating versions of
that but it is really nice and having
delved into the history of the school to
really think about our origins which I
will share with the rear-admiral we were
actually founded by Rockefeller
Foundation funding when they did the
gold mark report to look at public
health nursing originally they broadened
it later but it was about public health
nursing and then we became you know
probably the country's first
academically housed School of Nursing so
you know we really have this proud
history here at the school of service to
people in communities as well as
intellectual contribution to Nursing as
a discipline right and have it in this
place discipline that forms the
foundation of health systems everywhere
so each year it's a it's our pleasure to
a feature a remarkable individual who
follows in Sybil's footsteps someone who
expands the frontiers of health care and
strives to bring better health to all
people so with that in mind we're really
thrilled to welcome Rear Admiral silvia
trent adams as our 2019 bellos speaker
dr. Trent Adams became the principal
deputy assistant secretary for health in
January of this year and before her
current role she served as the deputy
Surgeon General of the US Public Health
Service as deputy Surgeon General Rear
Admiral Trent
was an essential advisor to the Surgeon
General helping support a variety of
critical issues including efforts to
combat the opioid crisis which remains a
current national crisis
most recently Rear Admiral Chen Adams
lifelong service was recognized with her
election in 2018 to the National Academy
of Medicine and the National Academies
of practice she has held several
leadership positions in Health and Human
Services working to improve access to
care for poor and underserved
populations as both a clinician and an
administrator she's had a direct impact
on building systems of care to improve
public health for marginalized
populations domestically and
internationally she's done at all she's
on the ball what she's done opiate she's
been everywhere as we think about nurses
like the Honorable Lauren Underwood who
was recently elected becoming engaged in
political leadership I thought it was
kind of telling to note that early in
her career dr. Trent Adams completed two
internships in the US Senate very
strategic dr. Trent Adams received her
Bachelor of Science in Nursing degree
from Hampton University and a Master of
Science in Nursing and Health Policy
from the University of Maryland
Baltimore she also earned a PhD in
public policy from University of
Maryland Baltimore County dr. Fred Adams
became a fellow of the American Academy
of Nursing in 2014 she received a
meritorious service medal for her
leadership during the commissioned Corps
response to the Ebola outbreak in West
Africa and Surgeon General's medallion
for her time spent as Acting Surgeon
General in 2017 she was the recipient of
the International Red Cross Florence
Nightingale medal the highest
international honor bestowed upon a
nurse please help me welcome
good afternoon everyone I am so excited
to be here I want to thank everyone for
your attention this afternoon and one
thank you for the opportunity to join
you to dinkar and the Yale University
administration thank you so much for the
invitation and the warm welcome and to
the faculty and staff hello good
afternoon and thank you for your
attention today you know this is always
an exciting time for me to come back to
my roots and nursing because there's so
much the nurses do that's often
unrecognized and we do play a
significant role in bridging the gap for
health disparities and I want today to
spend some time talking about how those
how those two areas collide and how I
have been able to be involved in some of
those things in my career so first as
you can see the title of my slide today
is 4:00 this afternoon is bridging the
gap addressing health disparities and
hope I get this right okay and as I do
in all presentations I have to say
they'll have no financial disclosures
that would protect you of potential
conflict of interest with this
presentation now my objectives today are
to talk about defying the bearers of
health and health care discuss the
impact associated terms of Health on
communities identify innovative models
of care at the community level focus on
comprehensive community-based care then
I want to talk close let me go back a
little bit because I want to talk about
the US you know in the United States we
made great strides in improving health
of our nation and especially over the
last century precision medicine vaccine
research drug development amongst others
have impacted our efforts to improve
chronic illnesses people are living
longer but where we fall short is
ensuring that optimal and equitable
health across all sectors of our
population can be achieved today I will
discuss some of the factors we need to
address in order to achieve a level of
success and through these objectives I
hope to accomplish that so I'm on this
slide in the last two years we've seen
it
and life expectancy across the United
States any qualities of life expectancy
among are occurring among counties that
are large and increasing over time and
specifically in underserved populations
in rural communities as well as with
subpopulations of of many communities
across the nation the difference in life
expectancy between the lowest-ranking
County and the highest-ranking County is
twenty point one years unfortunately in
this country your zip code dictates your
health outcomes more so than your
genetic code today I will discuss some
ways we are trying to change this
paradigm but let's begin the
conversation by discussing discussing
some of the barriers to health and
healthcare and I want you to note that I
said health and healthcare because there
are two distinctly different things as
we discuss communities and methods for
improving our overall health as a
society we need to address the current
barriers to health and healthcare and
how we as researchers as clinicians and
public health professionals can overcome
some of the health disparities and
health challenges plaguing our country
there are many structural barriers such
as transportation child care geography
social barriers many of these are
related to the systems in which we
employ to provide and deliver health and
healthcare services
now these system barriers are very much
real for those people who are in the
policy realm but they also do affect on
the frontline providers as much as they
perform in fact impact the policymakers
regulatory barriers impact the way in
which we deliver care regulatory
barriers dictate what you can and can't
do as a clinician many states how many
are aware of the nurse Practice Act as
being a major challenge and also as we
look at providing m18 medicated assisted
therapy for opioids buprenorphine
looking at who can provide certain types
of medications in structured
environments are directly driven from
regulatory and statutory policies
so looking at health disparities versus
health healthcare disparity and I want
to talk about the differences here we
must first define these terms
disparities in health and healthcare are
related but not synonymous concepts
health disparity refers to a higher
burden of illness injury disability or
mortality experienced by one population
group relative to another a healthcare
disparity typically refers to
differences between groups and health
insurance coverage access to and use of
care and quality of care more
specifically health and health care
disparities often refer to differences
that cannot be explained by variations
in health care needs patients
preferences or treatment recommendations
several related items such as health
inequality and health inequity are also
used interchangeably to describe
differences as socially determined
and/or deemed to be unnecessary
avoidable or unjust so the difference is
between having access to care versus
having access to insurance are very very
different now I can tell you from
traveling across the country and working
with a lot of underserved populations
there are many people the working poor
who may have health insurance provided
by their employers or on that they do
buy into a plan but there may not be a
provider who can meet their needs within
their geographic area or there may not
be a provider in their plan there may
not be a provider who provides the
specific services in their plan and at a
cost that they can afford so therefore
these these are very many there are very
many policy changes that need to happen
in order to ensure that everyone has
access everyone has access to they can
afford and when they have access they
can board and it can't afford they have
a provider who can provide that level of
care ok so I want to talk about the
factors associated with health
disparities so what are some of the
factors that contribute to disparities
this is kind of a complex issue that we
often struggle with and there are so
many complex and interrelated set of
group individual provider health system
and societal and environmental factors
that contribute to disparities and these
can exist in health and in health care
individual factors include a variety of
health behaviors from eight from
maintaining a healthy weight to
following med
boy advice and following up for
appointments or follow up to care that's
needed to maintain one's care and health
status provider factors encompass issues
such as provider bias and cultural and
linguistic barriers to patient provider
relationships and communication how
healthcare is organized financed and
delivered also shapes disparities as
youth social and environmental factors
such as poverty education and proximity
to health care and neighborhood sasai
that neighborhood or their safety so why
do healthcare disparities matter
disparities and health and health care
matter because they not only affect the
groups facing disparities but they also
limit the overall improvement in quality
and the cost of care and the healthcare
quality for the broader population is a
result of unnecessary cost so as you
know in any can innit in any community
where you have a high level of uninsured
individuals where they typically access
care in the emergency room where is the
most expensive place to access care the
emergency room because typically it
involves either someone walking in with
the condition and or illness that is
exacerbated to a point that it costs
much more to treat it and cure it or
resolve it than it does to prevent it so
these are some of the challenges that
many states and many communities are
facing right now so by having many
barriers to access and barriers to
addressing the disparities in healthcare
and also in health systems you know
there's a social justice component of
this as well but for improving the
health care of all Americans we have to
achieve improvements and achieve some
level of quality a high level of quality
at the optimum to achieve a high level
of access to population health care
moreover health disparities are costly
one analysis estimates that
approximately 30% of total direct
medical expenditures for blacks in
Spanish Hispanics and Asian's or excess
costs due to health inequalities and
inequities so what
social determinants of health I want to
talk about how education economic
stability food health status and health
care systems neighborhood and physical
environment can affect the health of one
individual community or an individual
these are indeed the social determinants
of health I want to give credit to the
Kaiser Family Foundation in this this
model was something that was released
several years ago but is my go-to
because it is the best depiction that
I've ever found that accurately and
appropriately define how the social
determinants Act the many many variables
that are in these different categories
so as we look at addressing these gaps
we need to address the gaps in ways that
will improve probably they should help
health through healthcare reform such as
the other horrible Care Act or many of
the other models that have been
established through many of the state
programs Massachusetts is a state that
started very early looking at health
care reform but Massachusetts is very
very unique and I'm often reminding
people when we have these conversation
but what about Massachusetts
Massachusetts is very special
Massachusetts has the following a very
solid high tax rate so their state taxes
cover a lot of health care you also have
a wealth of health professionals
training school institutions you also
have a lot of community health centers
for the free for free and sliding fee
scale possible care and you also have a
lot of nonprofits who provide free care
to individuals who are uninsured or
underinsured that is not the case in
every state in the United States
Massachusetts also made healthcare a
priority that is definitely not the case
in a lot of states what has happened in
Massachusetts is is now considered the
gold standard for some policy makers but
I would I would venture to say that
Massachusetts not necessarily the gold
standard it is the best that we've been
able to accomplish as a state is
concerned in the United States but it is
a place for us to start looking at as a
model whereby our health care can be
made available to all citizens and all
individuals who need care but what is
being done to address the gaps and so
with the social determinants of health
improving population health health care
delivery system
form and also looking at on the
healthcare delivery system as a model we
need to expand the scope of services to
meet the needs of individuals and
populations one of the things that I
often talk about when I do this
presentation is that most people don't
understand the the combination of health
healthcare prevention health outcomes
and saving money now the Economist
scratch our heads and go well you know
we need data so they'll always look at
actuarial data and see I was at CMS
yesterday we had these robust
conversations about how to calculate
risk how to calculate what's the best
cost for a service and it's it's all for
naught if you don't look at the real
cost and we are one of those cost
factors that never gets calculated into
the real cost of providing care nursing
services have to be at some point
factored into the unit cost of how care
is delivered it has to be calculated
into the need for Public Health nursing
at the community level to truly get to a
prevention model that would be
sustainable cost-effective but more
importantly the the main factor in how
people are able to stay well and not the
sick that's my public service
announcement for public health now I'm
going to do my best to stay on script
because you know Sylvia's a nurse
because it being the P - I'm still a
nurse and I so Santiago forgive me there
are a lot of there are a lot of things
happening right now in the within the
Department of Health and Human Services
as you heard earlier
yes we're spending a lot of time on
opioids we have a lot of priorities that
are focused on the social determinants
of health but not all of this is
determined social determinants of health
so you know in some cases they say you
have to flip the script depending on who
you're talking to and I learned that on
the hill my kids tell me that there's a
vernacular that I need to to learn how
to incorporate into my daily language in
my vocabulary my verbosity of terms from
a health policy world doesn't work with
the millennial generation so I'm going
to try to do my best year to to not use
so many words to communicate to you but
so flipping the script means that we
have to change the way
we say certain things to make sure
people can understand us better they
don't need to understand the value of
Nursing understand the value of
prevention and then understand the value
of making sure that everyone has access
to care right now if someone was to
articulate the real cost of not having
children immunize for measles in the
state of Portland Oregon the state of
Oregon in the state of Washington they
might pay attention but far to this
we've not been able to get public health
messaging on the forefront or the front
page of the New York Times and
Washington Post until there's a crisis
and that has to stop now within the
office assistant secretary for health
I'm going to tell you now I have I have
a great boss and he drives me crazy some
days because he has more energy than the
other but ever-ready bunny abra jawar is
very unique in that he understands the
need for change but he also understands
how to be a change agent he understands
the importance of having people who
understand the real problem on the front
line and just this week I think it was
two days ago we were in a we were on a
conference call and he acknowledged that
the most important provider in the
healthcare delivery system was nurses
[Music]
now part of that was because he had you
know a bunch of ammo nurses sitting in
the room
I happen to be taking the cup taking the
call virtually and I said sir I would
never contradict you when you are right
so we have we have a lot of advocates
for nursing and for prevention and
health care delivery system health care
delivery system reform within the
department Health and Human Services
right now I didn't know a lot of the
people who were coming in as a change of
it I've lived here let me say this I'm
going to date myself I am in year 32 of
uniformed service yeah I know I don't
wait nurses can do that but near 32 I've
lived through a quite a few
administration changes so right now I do
this somewhat I would do it in anything
else up pay patients come in patients go
right so you assess a problem you get
your nursing diagnosis then you develop
an intervention and then you evaluate
how effective you can be I use the
nursing process in every decision
process and every decision that I make
regards to the level within the
organization so that's what I need you
to do every single day when there's a
change change a professor changing class
whatever you need to do is invoke
whatever what you already know it's that
simple so when when the when average
award came on board I basically had to
size him up so to speak so what is this
guy really about but I didn't get a
chance he walked into her office and the
officer surgeon gentleman said he looked
at me he says oh you must be able to run
Adams I said I am he said mmm your
reputation precedes you and I didn't
know what that meant I and I and I just
kind of you know just said okay I'll see
how this goes everything that I've asked
him for related to nursing social
determinance of health prevention
activities he has supported
wholeheartedly and I will tell you not
everybody in the department always
agrees with him but he usually wins so
moving on what are we doing around the
social determinants of health
you know what's being done now is to
look at how we identify gaps and using
an opportunity using this opportunity to
improve population health and healthcare
system system reform but also looking at
what's already in place looking at the
Affordable Care Act which
constantly under scrutiny the National
prevention strategy which is ran out
that manage out of the office of the
Surgeon General and expand the scope of
services to meet the needs of
individuals and populations so what does
all this mean we have a roadmap and the
officers assistant secretary called Oh
ash and bear with me I'll use lots of
acronyms today if I say something you
don't understand it's got me within the
office assistant secretary these are
some of the programs that we manage all
these programs are intended to look at
the social determinants
look at how we can redefine reshape and
reinvigorate our healthcare delivery
system to better meet the populations
that we serve and that is within the
United States and abroad because I
didn't know this until probably I think
was in 2013 first time I went to the WH
o to represent the USGS as part of the
chief nursing council someone said well
what does the United States going to do
and I said well know what are you going
to do said no what is the United States
going to do and it took me probably
three seconds to realize oh she wants to
know what we're going to do because
there must be some value to it and as I
sat down in my seat I realized that this
was a huge opportunity but a significant
responsibility because when I sat in the
seat beside Marla Weston who was at the
arm AAA at the time and on this side was
Pam Cipriano we were the three go twos I
was representing United States as a
chief nursing officer for the Public
Health Service just by default becomes a
chief nurse for the United States and
together the three of us had an
opportunity not only to comment and how
do I say this politely have intense
fellowship with some people about some
things that weren't necessarily in
keeping with the spirit of moving
nursing forward for the 21st century and
we had a great time discussing
philosophical views and philosophical
beliefs but when we came out of that
room we all agreed that we have to stand
together 30 million strong across the
world and 3.3 million strong in the
United States because wherever you
wherever you are going to make change
you're only as strong as your weakest
link Nursing cannot be that weak link
and I keep reminding the physicians that
I work with as well as the pharmacists
I'm talking about opioids keep it up you
can always sleep wake up the sleeping
dragon because we're 3.3 million strong
and when we do decide to come together
and coalesce around central theme
central ideas and one agenda not 50
different agendas across all the states
one agenda we will be the dragon that
will be ruling the roost but that's
again a public service announcement for
nursing so these are some of the
responsibilities in the office assist
secretary for health and we do spend a
lot of time talking about how do we make
the system better how do we improve on
health outcomes and what are we going to
do for the next 10 20 30 and 50 years to
make sure that our children who are who
are being born today will meet the
medical as well as the physical
guidelines to be able to qualify for
military service we are in a crisis
right now because 70% 7 out of 10 youth
between the ages of 17 and 25 cannot
medically qualify for recruitment into
the military now if that doesn't scare
you I don't know what would scare you
and primarily the three different
reasons obesity so they don't meet the
weight requirements there is a or a
mental health condition that
disqualifies them or a criminal record
those are the top three so 70% of them
do not qualify so it is crazy you're
absolutely right it's crazy we're
working to to move the needle forward
and how we can address some of the
priorities within the department as well
as within the communities so what are
the some of the things that we're doing
in Ashe or we have some initiatives that
we've been working on for the last two
years but they are some of them are
carry ons from the previous
administration so with then on the area
of health disparities we're working to
develop the office of minority health
program to serve as a catalyst to new
framework for change and this means that
we're creating new innovative ideas to
reach minority populations that have
been left out by the healthcare delivery
system we want to look at language
culture and also recruiting providers
who look like the community to talk
about the community and can be an
invested stake stakeholder in that
community to be able to serve those that
they
represent and within implementing a
public health turnaround teams focus on
zip codes suffering the worst health
inequities with the commissioned Corps
well I'll talk about that in more detail
improving the availability of CPR
there's no national registry of CPR but
when we did a service CDC did a survey
probably 10 years ago they noted that
the communities that were most likely
not to have CPR for communities of color
world communities and communities with
high levels of violence so those are the
communities that need it most because
where do we see the largest disparities
of cardiovascular disease and in
minority communities and in communities
with high violence we want to develop
exemplar initiatives for minority and
underserved and or underserved
communities so when I say underserved
communities it includes minority
communities but minority communities
have been pulled out because of the
specific focus around health outcomes
and health disparities so moving on with
our our new initiatives around
infectious diseases we want to reduce a
new cases of HIV by less but by 50%
within five years we just launched the
ten year plan to eliminate HIV that is
receiving two billion dollars over the
next ten years and we've already stood
up several of the teams at CDC NIH and
hersa can you believe the federal
government coming together to talk to
each other quite amazing but this will
be this will be a continuation of the
HIV strategy the National hiv/aids
strategy the in-house from a few years
ago so what we're doing specifically
around HIV is looking at those
communities at 48 to 49 can 48 counties
that have the highest number of new
cases every year so we're doing teams
with staffing teams and three regional
offices with commissioned Corps officers
and we're calling that change the map
and these are pace teams which have been
developed through on the commissioned
Corps and I'll go into more detail about
how pace works a little bit later I want
to talk about interventions there but
we're sending with sending concentrated
efforts to three regional areas and one
will be Atlanta
Georgia area we have a regional office
in recall region for Atlanta Georgia the
southeast has the highest rate of
undocumented HIV and against in the
country
we're also looking at Dallas Texas
because we have the highest rate of
Hispanic new infections in Dallas Texas
and LA County Los Angeles for Nia is
where the third team will be and they
will be specifically looking at homeless
youth HIV infected and also those who
have comorbidities around the opioid
epidemic and then incentivizing adult
vaccinations through reimbursement
reform there's been a lot of work with
the National Vaccine program office and
the second offices secretary which we
also management Oh ash to look at how do
we best give advice about reimbursement
reform for only insurance companies but
self-insured providers such as large
corporations who insure their their own
employees and develop a national plan to
capac STDs I didn't know until a couple
of months ago we've never had a national
strategy or national plan around STDs so
that is this is what we're doing around
infectious diseases in many physical
activity guidelines for all Americans
developing a national plan for youth
sports participation and physical
activity charting underserved
communities and girls there's a lot of
data about physical activity and girls
you know that girls seem to drop out of
sports and other activities are related
to physical activity in middle school so
what is it about middle school for boys
is sin they disengaged from stem
programs in middle school and girls seem
to drop out of the physical activities
so there are a number of programs with
them they also say a social secretary
that are focused on getting girls
involved in sports Girls on the Run is a
big program that's being supported
nationally and also trying to take that
internationally and working with CDC to
do more messaging around healthy weight
and healthy body image for girls and
helping them to understand the
connection between diet and exercise
improving cardiovascular mortality as we
looked at the national core --decor
arrest registry we know that there's a
need to double the survival rates we
know that we can double the survival
rate of individuals who have access to
CPR
when it's witnessed by someone who knows
CPR and will increase the likelihood
that they'll be able to get help to get
to hospital cardiac care quite a
critical kidney disease HHS why we're
doing a comprehensive plan to improve
the outcomes and the cost of chronic
renal failure and end-stage renal
disease many of the dialysis companies
around the country or for-profit many of
them target underserved minority
populations and the rates are
significantly higher in some parts of
the country than there are in other
parts of the country
there's been no gold standard for
identifying the standard of care for for
renal dialysis and outpatient for many
places with them and within the u.s. so
this HHS efforts going to hopefully
raise awareness of kidney disease
increase awareness around the need for
transplants and also identifying
reimbursement rates that are
commensurate with the provided supply
and the service providers within a given
geographic area there's no reason why
there should be a three-fold increase in
cost in Mississippi for dialysis care
then there is in New York City and we do
see some price gouging in some of those
cases and using digital determinants of
health to help us to develop a better
legal and ethical scientific frameworks
to fully leverage social media for
public applications and this has been
this is really truly interesting the
Surgeon General and dr. Adams Jerome
Adams bless his heart he loves to be on
social media so some of us are more
challenged because we're so involved in
policy we're not always out and about
doing all the social media but he he
lives and dies by his social media
contacts he literally part of our staff
meetings used to be focused on how how
many tweets he had and how many retweets
but it's important to understand because
the population that he's trying to reach
are young people who need information
and we have to all be able to embrace
the digital age but not only do we need
to understand how to use it we need to
know how to promote it with our patients
and promote it within the communities
where we or we where we live and where
we work in part and the reason I say
that is because there are a lot of
people and I will tell you my mother
does not have internet
in our house atrocity crates when I go
home and I can't get a signal from my
phone there are still people who use
hard copies of everything and we need to
understand that the fastest-growing
population in this country are the baby
boomers some of the module digitally
connected and some are not and we still
need to live in that world where we are
able to meet the needs and demands of
both now is it okay to expect people to
have an email in some cases yes but in
rural America where I grew up an
apparatus County Virginia
not everybody has high-speed Wi-Fi that
is a that high-speed cable and Wi-Fi
don't exist in some of those places and
if there's a good rainstorm it'll wash
out whatever landline exists so we need
to be very respectful of this when we're
designing programs developing policy
because it does impact access I tell you
a little story a couple years ago we had
a crisis in the Indian Health Service
and I got a call from Secretary of
Christ he said silver need you to meet
us at three o'clock today I said okay so
I go downstairs meet with him and shoot
staff they said we need you to take a
trip for since it okay we need you to go
in and do a clinical assessment of this
facility and figure out what the heck is
going on I said okay and I said well
where is it
it's in South Dakota okay I'm thinking
of South Dakota okay well I've got on my
what's on my calendar for the rest of
the week okay just let me know we need
to do he said so by tomorrow I need you
to go up there I said tomorrow tomorrow
talk about being able to leave DC and
get to Baltimore Washington to the BWI
Airport and stop by the way stop in
Columbia pick up my clothes to get on
the plane to go to South Dakota that
night was it one of those experiences
where you say nurses can do anything but
when we got to Pine Ridge South Dakota
it was a reality check for me because of
poverty the isolation the weather and
just travelling long distances to get
from point A to point B for basic care
was overwhelming this was one of those
those times in your career you go okay I
didn't even know this existed anymore
but there are parts of the country that
still are very isolated they have high
need suicide we had a suicide cluster
there a few years ago and they we
recruited mental health
to come up and they all stay maybe three
months and three-month increments you
know anything about taking care of
providing good care to patients and
things around things like mental health
suicide prevention and and drug
overdoses you need to be have a
relationship with them you can't build a
relationship and rotating three people
you know people in every three months
ago at a chunk so we need to make sure
that we are we needed to make sure that
we were building a sustainable model of
care that was going to be someone who
was going to be there be committed
understand the needs of that community
and give them some of their time and
space so they would not continue to have
this cycling this in-and-out process of
being able to meet their needs and I
remember being in the in the conference
room with tribal leaders hospital
administrators and patients and what I
took away from the only thing I remember
from that blur of the naff ternoon was
this the patient's wanted to be heard
but the staff was so burnout they
couldn't hear the tribe was so focused
on things that were political that they
couldn't hear and we really need to be
there at that point in time to kind of
be the neutralizer and I remember at the
end of the that that day I said to the
tribal chief thank you for allowing us
to be here courtesy and respect honoring
their traditions but we have a bigger
problem than you think we have and what
I need you to do is to help us figure
out who needs to come to the table in DC
to be able to communicate what your
patients are what the patients here are
dealing with and then figure out what
the next step should be because right
now we're not going to get anywhere if
we don't all kind of check our egos at
the door and start to understand that
we're not here for a career sake we're
here because we need to build a system
of care for these patients and he looked
at me and he said unlike you I don't
know what had been happening there but I
sensed that he felt disrespected by the
team of people that preceded us but on
our team we had two nurses a hospital
administrator and someone who was there
to strictly be the advocate for the
tribe and I think having someone
that was not coming from senior senior
leadership in the department have the
deputy secretary chief of staff whoever
come was the best decision ever because
I said I stand today
I'm not Admiral atom's I'm not you know
the the deputy Surgeon General I'm here
at Sylvia a nurse who wants to help and
that kind of lowered everybody's
expectation but we were able to have an
open dialogue about what needed to
happen there and that's how we need to
engage their populations whether it's
digital whether it's addressing new
priorities or standing up a new
initiative to stabilize a crisis in a
healthcare delivery system now we're
also addressing the opioid crisis now as
many of you may know we are in freefall
with the opioid crisis and no end in
sight we're seeing pockets of the
country Ohio is getting ahead of their
curve but whatever we're doing with
supply demand it's not working and we
need to figure out how best to address
the needs across the entire delivery
system I want to talk about our health
care delivery system and how how
services are delivered because
patient-centered services have to be the
way of the future
we've been doing a lot of case
management we've done innovative models
of care delivery
we're also invoking telehealth and we're
using electronic health records and the
use of data for planning and design for
team-based care is there significantly
important to building a solid healthcare
delivery system but we cannot do it if
you don't have providers and patients on
the same page
policy makers are great at coming up
with great ideas and I can say that I've
been in the room the people who are who
sound like me look like me but we're not
always right and if you build it they
will come it's not the way to approach
underserved populations you have to hear
what the patients need and we also
working on a number of initiatives
around impact on community doing
evaluations that give us real-time data
on how service delivery models are
working also looking at intake and
output for who's coming in who's leaving
the health care delivery system from a
patient standpoint but also as a
provider standpoint from a provider
standpoint okay there are a number of
models that have been proven to be very
very successful now I'm a little biased
on this
because I grew up in the Ryan White
hiv/aids IV program has been able to
develop a model at the federal level you
have the administration of the program
and you are in the if which revised
statute requires them to engage
community at the state and local level
and it also requires that by law
community participants need to be a part
of all decision-making processes so in
the large cities we call them eligible
metropolitan areas
EMAS and many of you may be familiar
with us you have to have an advisory
board and that advisory board is
responsible for making decisions on
setting priorities of how the money is
spent so to do that you have to have
communities identify stakeholders
patients can have to be involved in the
decision making providers and all
different types of organizations
insurance providers they have to be a
part of the incision making process now
we look at what we're doing to improve
access to care and some of the most
underserved and rural areas and also
those areas that have what we call hot
zones or high impact areas we've been
using Commission : Public Health Service
so folks who wear this uniform and by
the way if anyone's interested in
joining us in this uniform we're always
looking for good nurses and doctor and
dentist but we're we and we develop a
pace initiative and it's prevention
through active community engagement
teams and these are the teams that are
being on place in those three areas
Atlanta and Dallas and Los Angeles to
take on the opioid crisis and what they
will do is provide very concentrated
efforts around decreasing the number of
new infections and definitely decreasing
the number of overdoses
so the Ryan White Care Act program as I
said in 1990 it was enacted into
legislation that created the Ryan White
program is administered through MRSA it
has also the model that helped to do a
transition of services under pepper
PEPFAR so theft far is the global
hiv/aids program funded out of the State
Department
PEPFAR does a transfer a financial
transfer on the State Department to HHS
so that person can that could develop in
nursing education partnership initiative
and sub-saharan Africa and they also
develop a medical education partnership
initiative in Africa and the goal is to
provide quality and to improve the
quality and availability of HIV services
across the domestic population for the
Ryan White program and globally for the
PEPFAR programs so just a cute few facts
about the Ryan White program
seventy-three percent of those
populations other population are mono
ethnic minorities and we have sixty two
point eight percent live below the
federal poverty level and forty four
point four percent are over the age of
fifty that is one of the fastest growing
populations is the elderly but we say
over fifty and on eighty four point nine
percent of the volume white clients are
virally suppressed which is phenomenal
because the average population the
general population according to CDC is
between 48 and 52 depending on when you
when you look at the data so they've
done a phenomenal job in being able to
improve viral suppression so the Ryan
White framework is a comprehensive
framework is the public health approach
to providing comprehensive care and
services that system of care provides an
opportunity for everyone to be involved
in the care delivery system it involves
service delivery policy assessment
capacity development and quality and
what we do in that context is we our
goal is to reach optimal health care and
health outcomes for everyone and we know
that we want to make sure that
low-income people living with HIV
receive optimal care and treatment
regardless of where they live many a
third of the programs in Ryan White are
in rural communities or serve rural
communities many of them are statewide
initiatives funded out of a use at state
state and national state or national
program but the vast majority of those
rural programs have access to services
for y and white they don't exist for
general primary care for the non HIV
infected population I should say so I
want to give you a little bit of a
background on versa
first minute anyone ever heard of cut so
you community health center program
great the hearses community health
centers serve more than 27 million
patients and about over fourteen to
fifteen hundred centers and there's over
12,000 service delivery
across the country including Puerto Rico
and and USVI Guam Micronesia and Saipan
so the health centers providing a
variety of HIV services 2 million HIV
tests were conducted annually every year
this it runs between two and two and a
half million more than hundred
sixty-five thousand patients with HIV
received medical care services at health
centers the community health centers
have been one of the biggest customers
of a Ryan White I think about two-thirds
of the community-based programs within
Ryan White are co-funded by Ryan White
community health centers maternal child
health bureau for the title five program
and also received title ten under the
the office of population Affairs for the
Planned Parenthood and then we want to
make sure that we link everyone to care
through HIV prevention services and prep
under under Ron White Authority you
cannot provide services to anyone who is
not HIV infected or at high risk for you
can test those who are high-risk but you
cannot provide them with prep but
community health centers have broader
Authority and they can provide prep so
their Co funded with Ryan White and
community health center funding it
increases the likelihood then be able to
being able to get access to prep so here
is the care continuum for Ryan White I
love this model like I said I full
disclosure I'm a little biased is that
the goal of Ryan White is early
intervention and early intervention is
broadly defined it's wherever you come
into the system you can get access to
care and there are serious steps for
people for someone who has HIV at doing
their initial diagnosis and where
they're getting they're getting tested
and being counseled that they get
diagnosed with HIV then they get linked
to care they're engaged or retained in
care they get it get on their
antiretrovirals and the goal is to
receive is to achieve viral suppression
this model is the model for all the Ryan
White programs whether it's part a B C
or D this is the continuum that we use
within that framework now I talked about
pace and pace is one of is one of things
I love paste because it is so innovative
is creative pace came out of a need for
substance use
and tobacco training for schools and for
ell schools elementary middle and high
schools and there were a number of needs
assessments conducted across the country
commissioned Corps officers volunteered
to be a part of case and their off-duty
time their nurses doctors pharmacists
engineers environmental health officers
they come together they create their
teams and they identify schools at high
risk for tobacco substance use mental
health conditions or obesity low
activities low low rates of activity and
they target those schools and they've
developed curriculum and they've
leveraged that we've leveraged the
expertise of the commissioned Corps
officers at all levels of training and
they've built these curricula specific
for the schools and in the language of
the communities that they serve so
they've gone out I think all ten regions
now have teams and each of these teams
work with a partner would work with park
work with in partnerships with the
schools as well as housing authorities
they work with the state and local
health departments to build a program
that meets the specific need of that
that community now and I'll say that
what you see in California may not be
what you see in Washington DC and it may
not be what you see in Alaska but
whatever you see in those communities or
within those teams is what's been
developed and designed specifically for
that community we had high rates of
tobacco use and some of the the schools
at the high school students including
traditional tobacco as well as vaping in
Alaska and the teams decided we're going
to do an e-cigarette initiative and
that's how we were able to get training
out to the schools
elementary middle and high schools and
the benefits is that these officers live
in the communities they work and live
and they're assigned to the health
centers or large medical centers where
these communities are located and
they're able to build trust with the
local communities and they are that have
a vested interest in improving the
health it also increases the visibility
of the commissioned Corps because many
people don't know who we are just on the
way here if someone thought we were an
outlaw pilot and the airport this
morning they thought we were Navy on the
shuttle to that to get to the rental-car
and then I don't know what the guy
thought I was
he passed me on the seat he kept saying
thank you thank you thank you but he
says there's a lot of metals and I just
said thank you I'm in the commissioned
Corps he said what are you you you you
like he said he said you a pilot I said
no I'm a nurse he says Wow okay
and the other thing that paced us is it
helps to develop the leadership skills
they're speaking to large groups of
individuals developing relationships and
improving their emotional intelligence
but it also desensitizes them to the
unknown because in many cases they don't
know what the communities need they live
in and work in these in these
environments but they have no connection
to the community until they start to
work with the schools work with the
health department so that the health
departments are saying you know we have
high rates of teen pregnancy well let's
let's figure out how we're going to do
this so they usually find the right
providers to be able to come in to give
them advice and counsel CDC FDA and NIH
will look at the curricula for them
validate them test them and then give
them some evaluation feedback for before
they start to implement their their
interventions within the community okay
I got you I see a little that look she
gives me so I'm coming to the close now
so you know these are I always like to
give take-home messages but at the end
of my presentations and it's because I
want you to have something about the
perspective that I'm trying to share
with you from this is just so we're
talking this is not how much banana this
is not HHS but this is what I will say I
based on my perspective we need to
invest more resources at all levels the
federal state and local to provide
access to quality of care for all we
need to shift from the sick care model
to a prevention model because if we
don't start to take prevention seriously
we'll be having this conversation 20
years from now yet again health and
health care are not just clinical care
we need to all remember that the
determinants of health play a key role
in our healthcare delivery system the
vast majority of healthcare and factors
are associated health happen outside of
the tertiary care system it happens in
the community so that's what we need to
be and that's what we need to be
investing
our resources addressing the social
determinants of health is everyone's
responsibility we all have a role to
play and we all have a vested interest
in making sure that our communities and
our country and our states that every
every place that we can see that there's
grass it's called the United States we
have a vested interest in it and I want
to close with it with a quote from
Justice Sonia Sotomayor and she says
that I quote I am an ordinary person who
has been blessed with extraordinary
opportunities and experiences unquote I
think that defines also what we as
nurses are able to do not everybody can
be a nurse I'm convinced of that I had
two cousins who tried but that just
wasn't their thing I'm thankful for law
school because they're wonderful lawyers
but you know being able to be a nurse is
it's truly a treasure we can connect
with people on a level that others can't
they trust us we are the most trusted
profession we are the most reviewed
profession when it comes to having that
social that human interaction I think
that our contribution to humanity and
society is tremendous we have to take
responsibility for our own space in our
own place in the community but also in
health care leadership and that includes
policy so I hope that each one of you
will find your voice and be able to
contribute to the decision making and
the policy making as relates to our
profession the future of this country
and the future of the and health and
safety of our youth thank you
so okay she heard you so teleprompting
with time on it and so she does I get
excited about nursing it in public
health but I did want to leave a few
minutes for questions if there are any
my question is around and once you see I
heard you say we aren't making the
progress that we'd like to me but what
can err is doing okay the opioid crisis
is real I think that the the one thing
that I've learned from this is that
education is critical education is one
of the most important factors around
prevention and let me just let me unpack
this for a minute there are many people
who don't even know what an opioid is so
friends and family your children's
teachers your their friends that your
church your synagogue or mosque wherever
you wherever you go wherever you where
you find in space that you can have a
voice you need to share first of all
what does knowing the basic 101 about
the opioid crisis and how we got here
understanding that everyone deserves a
right to have care and and we need to
also make sure that we're educated about
what we can do to prevent individuals
from first misusing substances but then
if there are misusing how do I get them
the care that can help them care that
they need and then how we prevent
someone from overdosing if we were in
the cave most of what 80% of overdoses
are happening in the community they're
not happening in the tertiary care
facilities and not having an outpatient
letting this happen in the community so
the not naloxone advisor to certain
reviews released last spring it's
critical for us to understand that
people in the community need to have
access to naloxone
I know providers are having some
difficulty with this there's a there's a
standing order at every pharmacy I think
now and all of the states Melanie got
the last two on board all 50 states and
territories have a standing order
enjoyed any pharmacy requests and
requests naloxone now
unintended consequences the nurse who in
New York who was was notified by her
health insurance company that they were
gonna drop her because she had a
prescription for naloxone and so they
started to go through you know her
history of prescriptions and so forth
they filled this up in a lot of time she
sounds a provider and I'm a nurse
practitioner at working a clinic and in
a substance abuse clinic so I need to
have naloxone in case someone overdoses
well I'm sorry but that puts you at high
risk so those are some of the things we
need to be aware of but also make sure
that we are education prevention
communicating with everyone that we can
get our hands on and also raising
awareness around us about the policy
implications of the opioid epidemic
we're making some progress but supply
and demand
it's just vicious and we're not even at
the tipping point yet some areas have
you know it start to you know see a
flattening out of the plateauing but
we're nowhere near the end of this
epidemic right thank you for being in
the position you're in
we're blessed to have you your
presentation was very revealing for your
work so thank you and being career I can
say all kinds of things about you know
the history oh it did that before it
didn't work but here's why I didn't work
and people are starting to listen to
that you know I know and more often than
not I'm still often the only only
something and I want to say this guy for
a minute let me just hit this two nurses
okay so nurses or people who want to be
nurses there are things that are going
to come your way that are going to
discourage you that will beat you down
just shake yourself up knock the dust
off get back up and go at it again if I
could tell you how many people in the
course of my career told me that a I
will never forget this that you know
maybe you maybe you not cut out to be a
nurse they were right I wasn't cut out
to be just a nurse I was cut out to be a
nurse a scientist
a researcher a policymaker the deputy
Surgeon General the Acting Surgeon John
and the principal deputy assistant
secretary for health that's what I was
cut out for and you see and I don't
apologize for being a nurse ever and I
said we should have asked a nurse and
oftentimes I have to gauge the room a
little bit because I'm you know
sometimes I'm the only nurse the only
woman the only person of color
the only condition or the only person in
uniform and this happens all the time
but it's okay because you know what what
doesn't kill you does make you stronger
I wouldn't I wouldn't encourage you to
do some of the things that I've done in
my career I've had to take my lumps um
sometimes but it has made me stronger as
a leader it has made me more
compassionate towards people every
opportunity that comes your way brings
you something to learn I had some very
interesting I won't call them bad some
very interesting and challenging fathers
sometimes what they taught me was how
not to treat people I'm very very
careful how I treat the people that I
work with and I try to respect
everyone's opinion there sometimes I
have to just say no we're not doing that
but I try to hear them out first if we
don't agree I often tell them why I
don't agree I usually try to do that
I've got this one colleague boy she's a
nurse too we issued but she's a psycho
sir psycho have some special
perspectives on things I love them and
and and she knows that she and I are
usually gonna be in these these
Kennedy's two camps and I said that's
very true however from a financial
perspective we can't do that is what
we're going to do and sure use it goes
but I listened to me I said mm-hmm I
hear you and we move forward and then
when something unfolds as we continue to
go down the pathway she goes now I see
what you were talking about I said yes
because a policy the legislation the
clinical application that management the
leadership all have to come through my
brain at warp speed and after having
gone through some interesting times
challenging times you just do
fellip muscle memory around that you
able to think on your feet be able to
make decisions faster not too fast and
always never be too haughty to say
you're sorry when you make a mistake on
it because every day and pardon me
gentlemen but every day you have to get
up ladies and put on your big-girl pants
and go to work because it's important
for you to understand that you have to
make decisions but make decisions that
are informed that are well-founded and
that will serve best not only you but
those that you that you serve that's my
soapbox for leadership in a nutshell yes
ma'am first year PhD students and my
issues with obesity prevention I'm
hoping to catch that first five years
expansion anyways
any words of wisdom from your
perspective from the hill first of all
congratulations on starting that
wonderful journey of PhD good for you
secondly thank you for your interest and
veterans you're absolutely right this is
this is a challenging time
many of them have comorbidities
associated with depression and so forth
the best thing to do is create a
partnership with where you can find the
captive audience and I wouldn't go to I
wouldn't necessarily say that the VA is
the best place to go to get them you
need to work with some folks who are
doing transition with the active duty
component or the Reserve Component
because you have the active duty
component who are doing their day job
every day but then you have reservists
to also leave that reserve environment
and I can get you in touch with some
folks who do transition coordination at
DLA at DoD the defense health agency is
where a lot of the health components are
and we have a nurse who's a certain
Delta Air Force don't da Dorothea Hogg
is is that surgery on the Air Force
nurse and she is a good resource but
there you have chief nurses of each one
of the services who have a huge
bandwidth and a lot of influence of the
services and can tell you exactly how to
go
about getting the information that you
need but I'm happy to work with you and
get you a point of contact yes sir
yes I'm LaRon Nelson associate or 400
health that we here I want to know your
perspective on the relevance or
acceptability of the pace program that
you describe what happened to address
the initiative to reduce HIV infections
by in five years or ten years it wasn't
I the examples you use when you describe
them but I I looked at that which is
rare or something that is interesting to
me I thought about can paste memories to
help address that issue that's exactly
the initial s what we're standing up so
we are creating a team of teams of three
initially and three of those three areas
the pay's teams will have a coordinator
Regional Coordinator and will have two
staff working with those coordinators
they will be responsible for working in
those regions to work with the state and
the local and the County Health
Department's city and county health
department's to identify where they'll
do a needs assessment and figure out
where have you been not able where you
not able to reach these individuals
there our goal is to select paste'
members and leadership that will be able
to engage with the leadership in the
regions and develop programs through the
community health centers maternal child
health programs and also on the Sam
success abuse mental health services
administration programs today I go into
the community though the barbershops and
laundromats the car dealerships or ever
shooting galleries night clubs like we
did in them in the old days but wherever
there is a need and there's a population
that can't be reached because we're
trying to target men who have sex with
men and minority populations in the
southeast and in Texas
because there we've not been able to in
to infiltrate that population we've not
been able to get them in we've not been
able to have them come into care
routinely and had that retention and
care so we have to figure out what needs
to happen there each of these models
will be different but those pays teams
will be invested in serving on the HIV
program and the opioid program primarily
but we're also doing vaccine
with HIV substance use with HIV because
all these comorbidities for underserved
populations high-risk populations all
live in the same universe so is it a
public health approach focus on those
first two high-priority solo people it's
an HIV so I hope that can come back and
tell you that pace has been successful
and being able to help to lead in an
area where those health department have
been able to document decrease in new
infections that was correct
yeah those that's what we're starting
initially so these are there will be a
three year project and then based on the
results of the first three years we'll
determine whether that we will continue
to have those programs funded I think we
will because I think this high need and
all of at least eight of the ten regions
right now around HIV but we'll see yes
sir so I'm okay I guess I'm also a first
year PhD student studying HIV and
substance use and previously worked as
an HIV nurse so I think downstream I
benefited from your leadership and my
previous job had a question about so
there's all these there's this really
robust instead of outreach to different
regions of the country and to state
departments and local health departments
in the hill but on the structural
conditions for both implementation
apartment a lot of policy developed
comes out of state legislatures which
are generally both sort of understaffed
and have part-time jobs and you know we
saw for example in Portland and
Washington that there were state laws on
the books and from legislators who was
it educated is there any kind of program
in this outreach to what educate state
legislators beyond just the county
health department but the funders
themselves yes that is exactly what the
pace coordinator will Division
coordinator will be doing they'll be
looking so working across the entire
department these individuals most of
them have are have have history of
working with multiple agencies within
HHS and outside of HHS so that will give
you one example there's one individual
that I know of he's worked at hersa he's
worked at NIH he's worked at CDC so he
knows has relation
with all of those those folks so we nose
care delivery knows I'm the epidemiology
team gather that data build a white
paper and pass it off to the to the
state legislature legislators I'm just
say here is information for your for
your benefit now with a what they do is
within the region's the regions are
managed by the regional directors which
is a political and they have a list of
priorities that they focus on based off
the department and other parts of the
government but what is not said is that
they also act as advisors to the state
legislators and the governor's office so
depending on the relationships between
the regional offices and the legislators
or the governor's office they can or
they may not have as much anymore but I
will tell you what the health
department's do listen to the Regional
Health administrators which are Oh ash
the the report to the assistant
secretary actually afford to me but
forgot that they report to me and we
strategize off of how to best engage
with the stakeholders the advocacy and
education groups and what are the major
priorities in a given jurisdiction based
off of the data that we have now the EPI
profiles that are produced by CDC give
you a whole host of scenarios that you
can choose to play out in a given
community what's happening right now in
Atlanta is that we have individuals who
are at high risk for eligible for
certain services or may not even know
they're eligible for services so I want
the pace team that goes to Atlanta to
look at all the CDC data look at the
Samsa data
look at that hersa data and just do an
amalgamation of all that - you know
basically overlay all these maps and
look at where are the new infections who
are the points of entry and then who are
the stakeholders that have access to
that population and for a lot of these
communities is the faith-based community
so I need people who can go and talk to
the faith-based leaders who have
contacts in the legislature who have
contacts in the health department to
pulled it everyone together there'll be
they won't be the conveners per se but
they'll definitely be the innovators
providing information and supplying
ideas and helping them to write the
proposals for policy change
very powerful position I mean these pace
coordinators can really change the map
and that's the goal is to help
individuals who don't know where there
are pockets of funds to match their need
to match the community's demand then we
can start to pull these all these
programs together and hopefully make
some changes yes sir
last question we we have 44 million
Americans who live in counties that do
not have adequate primary care
practitioners and it's estimated over
15,000 physicians would be needed to
fill that gap but that's not going to
happen could you comment on how nurse
practitioners could be should be might
be deployed to address this this acute
shortage in primary care practitioners
in such a vast swath of the United
States I'm glad you asked that question
because this is something that secretary
aids are met with all of the non
physician direct providers last fall I
had the privilege of being in that room
and I heard him say one of the things I
want to accomplish and my time here is
to look at innovative ways to encourage
the states to expand their their
thinking around using nurse
practitioners pas it's basically the
military model of care and I mean we use
poor men we use nurse practicioner
strategy to run clinics I was an O three
running at the outpatient clinic you
know you you have providers you managed
you manage the staff that you have
telehealth was something I've talked
about but what he when he said but
didn't say was that we hold the purse
strings and let's see how much
reimbursement and my system redesign can
be configured to better encourage states
to look at scope of practice look at
prescription privileges look at zoning
for high-risk types of activities such
as HIV infectious diseases as well as
comorbidities associated with some of
the higher go
and TV I think reimbursement is how he's
going to approach it because that does
send demand signals to the AMA and WMC
so we he is he's full-on I've been
really shocked to hear some of the
conversations at this level that I
didn't even know we're even on the
agenda but definitely scope of practice
and and looking at cash shifting I know
you still miss my last question I make
this comment what we did in Liberia and
what we did in West Africa with with
Ebola was phenomenal but it was because
we let the people who knew what they
were doing do what they were supposed to
do and we got out of that way what we
did in PEPFAR and Malawi Tanzania
Mozambique and DRC the Democratic
Republic of Congo who's having a bold
outbreak right now what we did there was
that we did a lot of tests shifting we
stopped nurses from doing blood
pressures and vitals for screening and
triage we did not let them go get
medical records we had volunteers for
the community health workers did all the
outreach and we shifted the clinic model
completely around to make sure that and
this wasn't just us it was having the
providers in the community the providers
in the clinic and volunteers when whu-oh
helped us to redesign this model so that
we could we weren't only able to see 80
patients a day we were able to move to
seeing 200 patients a day and one small
rural clinic which is phenomenal I mean
at 6 o'clock in the morning you've got
50 people lined up for care by 7 o'clock
you've got 150 in the queue so you could
change that the model routine care done
by nurses who have been trained in
prescribing you had their labs that were
made available to them you had community
health workers coming in to do the labs
and get them all get all the charts
ready in the morning they briefed out to
the providers what was needed and we it
was a well-oiled machine if you ever get
a chance to go to Malawi go by
lighthouse and you can see that model in
action but that's what we need in rural
communities with so we need a lot of
urban communities is having a
task-shifting approach to looking at
what a nurse is trying to do what a
nurse
trying to do what a physician is trained
to do what a pharmacist is trained to do
get out of their way and let them do
their work and stop looking at this as a
capitalist model this is not a
capitalist model this is a healthcare
delivery model that we need to build
that will best meet the public health as
well as a healthcare tertiary healthcare
needs of the patients that we serve and
I think I'm getting a look
[Applause]
[Music]